30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
fear on the App Store or Google Play
with so much information and diet trends
out there high fat low cup high cup
intermittent fasting and more it is no
wonder that we get confused with the
right way of eating in this video I'm
going to share with you the five biggest
dieting myths on weight loss by looking
beyond opinions and focusing on the
science I'm sure we have heard that
eating breakfast will make you less
likely to binge during lunch
in fact I myself have said this in my
previous videos this is not an untrue
claim by any means
however skipping breakfast will not
cause your metabolism to slow down and
still help with weight loss especially
for those who are practicing
intermittent fasting the bottom line is
if skipping breakfast makes you more
likely to binge later on in the day on
unhealthy snacks because you are
extremely hungry and struggle to make
wise decisions then don't skip breakfast
but if you genuinely are not hungry you
don't have to force yourself to eat
breakfast this myth proposes of that
eating five or more smaller meals in a
day will raise metabolic rates which
means burning more calories now it is
true that when you eat you increase your
metabolic rate slightly by increasing
the thermic effect of food that is
calories burn from consuming food
however the additional number of
calories burn is very minimal at less
than 10 percent of the total amount of
calories you burn in a day this means
your food intake frequency has a
negligible effect on metabolism to help
you lose weight long term if you want to
lose weight and sustain a healthy weight
long term eating more frequently isn't
the most reliable method
if you genuinely like eating smaller
more frequent meals than go for it but
don't force yourself to eat more meals
in hopes of losing weight some of you
could end up consuming more calories
which as we all know will lead to weight
gain what affects your basal metabolic
rate the most is your body composition
so the more lean muscles you have the
more calories you're burning at rest a
part of fat free tissue burns about 14
calories a day while a pound of fat only
burns 2 to 3 calories while the
difference may not sound a lot it will
have a significant effect over time so
focus on increasing more lean muscles by
including strength training exercises
into your routine intermittent fasting
has a growing following and I'm sure
some of you might be on this eating
pattern as well for those of you who
might be new to this intermittent
fasting is the practice of consuming
know of very few calories for a time
period that can reach between 12 to 16
hours and limiting their feeding window
to between 8 to 12 hours this has been
said to be effective for overweight
adults because of the fat metabolism
benefits that kicks in as the body
switches to fat as a source of film
which occurs after 12 hours of fasting
saying that however intermittent fasting
isn't the only way to tap into fat
metabolism calorie restriction has been
shown time and time again to increase
fat metabolism especially when combined
with exercise both exercise and
nutrition influence fat metabolism for
some individuals exercising while
fasting can be a huge challenge and this
can result in a decrease of cognitive
function and also your physical
performance now the bottom line is to
manipulate our body's weight up or down
we need to manipulate the energy balance
equation both calorie restriction and
fasting
and considerably reduce calorie intake
and bring about similar health benefits
in a way they're like siblings because
studies on fasting initially emerge from
the work of calorie restriction what's
most important when it comes to weight
loss is to follow a sustainable
lifestyle
if intermittent fasting works for you
then great but if you're forcing
yourself to follow this eating pattern
but unable to sustain it long-term then
you must find an eating pattern that
works for you I'm sure you have come
across this common phrase eat clean
what does it mean eating clean means
eating whole foods rich in nutrients
which are minimally processed yes all of
us should strive to eat clean the issue
comes when they solely focus on quality
and ignore quantity it's all about
consumption / it's in calories will
result in weight gain and under eating
calories will result in weight loss
regardless whether it is good or bad
calories does this mean that if you
watch your calories you can consume
processed food and still lose weight yes
and no because not all calories are
created equal if you consume more good
calories you will be feeding your body
with essential vitamins and minerals
have more energy feel satisfied hence
eating less and improving your overall
state of health now if you have a diet
filled with bad calories you'll suffer
from lack of energy poor health and your
body will be lacking the vital vitamins
and minerals in needs to perform at its
optimum and you will be craving for a
lot more bad foods the bottom line is
aim to eat clean while being conscious
of how many total calories you consume
in a day
this leads unto my final myth
[Music]
yes counting calories and limiting your
daily calorie intake will lead to weight
loss but let me ask you this are you
prepared to count calories and control
what you eat forever let's be real and
ask yourself how long can you stick to a
strict regime wring out all your food
counting every single nut having no
social life by avoiding eating out or at
your friend's house because you're
trying to maintain that strict regime
this sounds really depressing as I've
mentioned before not all calories are
created equal you may think that you can
drink tight sodas all day long because
they contain zero calories but know this
they will cause damage to your body your
metabolism and your gut microbes long
term eating processed and artificially
developed low calorie foods can actually
lead to weight gain because they
interfere with our body's natural way of
breaking down and storing food yes it is
very important for you to have knowledge
and the basics in regards to food
calories but at the same time not being
overly obsessed with every single
calorie you eat because long-term you
could develop an unhealthy relationship
with food
another piece of advice is to not starve
yourself and cut calories drastically
this is unhealthy and not sustainable if
you want to lose weight and keep it off
forever
you need a modest calorie restriction
that you can simply continue and never
stop the bottom line is it is not one or
the other
yes be aware and know the calories in
food at the same time practice mindful
eating and nourish your body with
wholesome clean food so which are you
are you a breakfast person do you pay
for having more smaller meals or fasting
and eating big meals whatever you're
eating preference is remember this all
dietary patterns should be derived from
one simple principle which is an
balance overeating calories will result
in weight gain and under eating calories
will result in weight loss regardless of
the time you eat in the day or the
source of calories
what other dieting myths have you come
across do let me know in the comments
below if you like this video do give it
a thumbs up share this video on and
remember to subscribe to my You Tube
channel and hit the notification button
so that you will get notified every time
I share a new workout video recipe video
or even nutritional tips all the best